gang big news the ru garbage middle
class famous tour is coming to
california and you don't got to wait
long baby we're going to be in san
francisco on april 3rd we're going to be
in los angeles california april 4th and
april 6th we're going to begin it
so grab the squad and come out and see
us
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage
it's a little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out they
grow up to be classy yeah or is it just
a big old piece of trash i'm your host
age foley coming at you on a beautiful
day down here in aunt toddy's basement
she's upstairs switching from vodka to
gin okay solidarity so look at that
right there we're all doing our part
over here
my co-host is coming at you from across
the table he is the brand new hot driver
in the nascar sprint series
if you ain't first your last
i'm gonna be running at the motor
speedway this weekend a dirt track man
myself
driving the double zero pabst car give
it up give it up for colt ryan everybody
what are you doing
living my best life baby
you know got to support the brand it's
american brand got to support got to
support you know that's what i'm doing
what's up everybody thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube and as you know those numbers
are true the roof cooking uh and
obviously uh patreon.com the greatest
website of all time shout out to them
boys tweet lord and gals over there
doing the [ __ ] lord's work sign up
you get bonus content episodes of ayg
which uh episodes are hard feelings or
just me and a big man behind a curtain a
little bit more a little hr a little
airing of the grievances sticking each
other uh check it out it's a good time
thank you and how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good
it's t-bone mcscuffins toby mcbuttons
everybody what up dudes what up
dude kimmy looks like he brings his own
helmets to the go-kart
i got a mic in there
you know the hell's my pit crew acting
you fall in both worlds it could be cool
or you also looked at the guy like the
guy that goes to every met game
you're that guy you look like you've got
that jacket out of a claw machine
that's a pretty expensive pole machine
this isn't a chalk line original by the
way you guys walking around like a drunk
astronaut look at you stakes
that has scream and a t-ball written all
over it oh yeah
uh big fan of paps i was watching
downton knights last night that's a good
[ __ ] piece of business got that uh
yeah it got me pumping i was like you
know what i gotta break it out today
been waiting been waiting for the
perfect moment to break this out yeah
yeah where did you get it online
chalkline.com what credit card did you
apply for to uh
to receive this i put this on the
business amex by the way i'm wearing it
on screen it's a wardrobe cost
how how many paps caps did you have to
send it for it
are you gonna get the key or wrapped in
pap [ __ ] i would if they would pay for
it i would drive a [ __ ] pabst kia
around town man remember when that
started happening perhaps would sponsor
our tour or us in general this is a
power play i'm doing here
this is a money play all right
you two are sitting around thinking i'm
a bozo they're not touching the jeep
it's a goddamn lease what are you doing
i'm gonna have paps on your forehead
next week
i'm gonna i'm gonna be selling out your
[ __ ] belly you're gonna be doing this
shirtless paddy's walking around head to
toe pabst
do you remember when that i kind of feel
like i remember what when that really
started to happen like uh
like around role models time when people
were like selling their
car like people were driving around like
monster energy a lot of like a lot that
was when like brand reps were big huge
dude the beer rep would show up yeah but
like people would like freelance as
though as the reps you know what i mean
they would be like like i used to work
when i was like in an office job and
like girls on the weekends would be like
i'm doing a whatever event they would
make like 120 bucks giving out like
monster or whatever like stand at the
tent or whatever man some pt cruiser
wrapped like fig newton the big the
trashiest of traps like fake newtons
that's the perfect car to rap for a
newton is a [ __ ] pt loser
let me tell you something on the newton
subject
i've i've recently uh rekindled my love
affair for the fig newton sure the
healthy cookie but i know what you're
thinking i'm having one i'm having one
at a time it's the nature ones they're
real thick they're like double stuff
blueberry [ __ ] nice gluten-free too
so it's funny yeah you'll be under four
hundo in no time
i'm on the fig newton diet yeah once can
you come and be like carrots are good
everybody i'm gonna be carrick i've got
carrots this weekend delicious
deep-fried butter
um
yeah
but the trashiest rap was that where we
were the trashiest rap was the hummer
people would wrap the hummer like [ __ ]
especially like or like every strip club
in philly down at like down by the
airport like that run they all had the
hummer they would show up to like the
tailgating events with like [ __ ]
chicks with cannons and like there would
be like little kids i remember that the
back yeah i remember catching some of
those as a kid that's real
pro bowl vibes oh yeah pro bowl weekend
in [ __ ] arizona girls and girls
twerking next to a bag of [ __ ]
tournament that shit's trash the the
strip club limo
decked out is a tough look the the
hummer club anything and not
anything from a strip club club outside
in public is a tough look have you ever
had them send the limo for you what
what
what
send the limo for me
what am i a big spender i'm in there
picking pennies off i'm picking dollars
that these broads are dropping i'm
splashing around in the puddles when
people are making it rain 50 cents a
dance ryan over here
one of those little change coins honey
honey folding money only
[Laughter]
can you break a five i folded what is
this dead wood
paper bills or teeth or treasure t bills
how do you uh on what on that similar
line how do you feel about the uh the
courtesy car from the dealership that's
a tough look
it is a real tough look and listen i'm a
killer man that's what i can afford at
this current state in my career i drive
at kia
i've never really been a lug i've never
driven i don't think i think i've driven
to be in my buddy's bmw i think uh i've
driven that
but
he's gotten it where a lot of those bmw
dealerships if your car goes in it's
important you gotta you know you gotta
import all the bra it's tough it's not
like that's different but that says i've
i would be pissed if i spent money on a
bmw
jamie kennedy chevrolet well that's what
i'm saying no they do that on the
beamers it'll say like [ __ ]
you know edison new jersey
oh no of course yeah yeah i would be
pissed if i paid for a beamer and you
give me a [ __ ] i'm driving around in
a wrapped car you look like a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i spent enough money i'm not dr
i'm not your [ __ ] billboard on 95. i
would be [ __ ] pissed i mean the
renter that they give you yeah they give
you the loaner card and it says like
johnson bmw yeah no that's no good
that's the auto mall
i'm talking about the one where where a
dealership guy drives that and picks you
up and brings you back in a beamer
that's okay no that's worse than a
beamer you're driving a luxury car that
has like on the back windshield like
johnson's bmw well my mom used real
traffic my mom used it last week for her
car and the guy picked her up in like a
96 windstar
i'll take the [ __ ] bmw
spray paint over the name probably what
does she say where was she going she was
going to pick the car up after i got
serviced oh and they came to pick her up
like a shuttle not like the loner cars
like a shuttle car just like some some
[ __ ] poor schmuck on his lunch break
they were like go pick up paddy that's
what happened smoking in here what
i smoke crack the window
stop being a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh dude using the car lighter still i
remember that guy showing up a couple of
times throughout my life when the car
was in the shop or something like that
we never oh yeah we're this is where we
differ our family we wearing a
dealership that's where they [ __ ]
bamboozle i do i get nervous driving by
a dealership
where are you from cars front lawn by
the mailbox yeah we're person to person
yeah
we don't do that i love when they pull a
car out right by the mailbox it's all
it's funny it's funny to say that so my
stepdad ran into some car trouble
recently
and his was uh
his was out of commission for a while so
his buddy has a used car lot so he
bought a used car off this guy because
it was supposed to take like
lot versus dealership is a huge
difference
that's what i'm saying we're a lot
familiar
it's really like the guy's house it's a
trailer it ain't like college university
no it's a couple of pegs down yes go
over there on the lot that's right
that's why i've gotten every car is off
from this guy
my picture's on the wall in his little
office that has it's like me next to the
lumina and me next to my montego we
don't but you go into a dealership he's
staying there running the odometer
backwards oh yeah
he's got the back propped up wheels are
just spinning three miles it's an 86
belong to an old lady garage cap what do
you want
yeah dealership's nuts to me
we would never you got to know a guy you
don't buy to us if you buy a car off a
dealership oh we own what do you thinks
pay for all the coffee and donuts we
always do guys we always knew a guy but
we never there was always somebody
working for somebody also to get i guess
if you were leasing two but to get a fix
we would never go to a dealership to get
it fixed
we would just let it sit in the driveway
for six months until the neighbors
complained that my stepdad finally
pulled the trigger on it maybe the holes
will rust up so his car was jammed up
right for it was going to be like months
they said months yeah i don't want to
get into it this is going to be a long
time some engine problems
i got to go to physical therapies
because i'll do highway driving to begin
with that's it not a lot of starting and
stopping for three weeks
so well that's what they said they're
like this is gonna they had to like redo
the whole engine or something he bought
a lemon i get bought a bra it's a huge
truck huge pickup truck so redo the
engine something happened and so he
bought a used car off off this buddy who
has the lot sure right of like
well i'll just zip around in this until
my [ __ ]
it's
it was like an audi you bought for like
six grand it's like like a 90 or like it
might be like a 99 audi or whatever
that's good yeah probably all beat up
it's a convertible it's not it's nice it
doesn't make any sense that this guy's
driving this fight he looks like he's in
the russian mob or something
so
i just on the phone with my mom
yesterday he goes oh his truck's
finished early you know whatever it
wasn't as bad as they anticipated he
could go pick it up and go what's he
going to do with the audi because he's
going to park it out for out front of
his office with a for sale sign on it
wow and see if anybody if he gets any
takers flip it so we're currently
working if anybody out there is in the
in the market for a beat up audi hey
probably not that beat up don't listen
to kevin it probably looks nice and it's
a convertible and don't forget spring
time start right around the corner
that's what he said he was gonna wait
for the first night's nice day and put
the top here yeah then we show off the
merchandise let's get sharp i'll tell
you that right now between that and
lottery tickets this guy's a gentleman
in my house
right now
yeah so we're currently selling our own
cars at the moment if anybody's scared
it says 6000 obo
uh it comes as is by the way those seat
holes were in it sullivan ryan motors
sullivan ryan kelly motors what's the
giveaway situation on the weekends you
get 20 seconds in the cash booth
you grab as many singles as you can
three hot dogs for the kids come on down
that's where you got the jacket from man
you've been playing you've been playing
this all weekend sides against the
middle
this guy's always making money
even when i'm wrong i'm right
you look like you're about to take the
shot from center ice
then it's back to your mail route
i'm walking all slow from the bench
easy does it kippy huh
yeah
that jacket came with a big check
it's written in glitter jiggy
want to talk about a home run the moon
shot
shout out to semi-pro if you haven't
head down to the video store and pick
yourself up a copy it's a killer
oh gang
you could never wear that again you know
that right i can pepper it in oh man
let's come from the guy who wears the
same clothes every single day to the
point where you said you smell like a
homeless man and you're allegedly
also someone commented you thought it
was the juices inside of you that's what
you said the juices inside you went bad
i could i think so
yeah now because because of what i've
been eating my sweat isn't as pure as it
was when i was a young man that's pure
yes yeah i guess this is high quality
[ __ ] we're tall this is unstepped on age
foley juice we're talking
you're an idiot well what you eat
determines how your sweat smells
and taste
i don't know if that's the case
yeah it does
that's why if you eat like garlic it
tastes like garlic sure okay garlic yeah
i don't think the juices inside of you
were bad but there's a thing you also
said you didn't watch those [ __ ]
basketball shorts for like six months
which i think that might be the problem
if we're [ __ ] splitting
those things man cave puts oh man it's
insane that anybody shares a bed with
you it's crazy poor girl oh my god
all right
what do you got let's get into some
questions guys so as you know when you
sign up for the patreon we will read
your garbage question on the air uh it's
just the best way to do it we can hit up
[ __ ] people dm on instagram twitter
email but uh patreon gets first crack at
it
and uh we got a couple this one's just
funny this is from a ligament balls
first time i can't take him seriously
you're calling a calling a cubs game
[Laughter]
trying to get his children's affection
yeah you got your kids the batting cages
nine o'clock on a wedding
heat too
that's my plate that's my plate junior
[ __ ] giving them the high i'm buzzing
them
i own the inside
hey my son or not i own the inside of
that plate you walk into the batting
gauge and turn the machine off
i got it from here
i got i got half of it on
i was gonna stay warm
cut to me on the patreon i'm all like
stop
full pack of seeds in your mouth
looking like the big leagues [ __ ] boy
robin's racing
good lord
let's talk about movement baby move man
you know movement you gotta watch i
gotta watch i got sunglasses i got
glasses
cool stuff started out small department
couple of college buddies wanted to take
on the big boys and that's how movement
was born yeah fantastic fantastic
cool looking stuff for half the price
yeah uh movement watches have the look
and quality of four to five hundred
dollar watches that you're paying for at
a department store but at a fraction of
the car
because they were built online and their
own process from start to finish you get
a beautiful watch tip right to your door
for free and if you don't love it you
can ship it back for free as well nice
big thing they also got they got the
blue light glasses everybody's spending
so much time on your computer your phone
the whole nine yards their everscroll
blue light filtering glasses are a game
changer my wife uses them every day when
she's working it really helps with eye
strain and poor sleeping patterns and
you'll love the modern look of the
frames they don't look you're not
sitting there in like 3d goggles they
look like regular cool guy frames right
or cool gal frames you know ladies got
to pair them as well if you want to
elevate the look and look with style
that doesn't break the bank then join
movement and get 15 off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
mvmt.com garbage again that's mvmt.com
garbage do it yeah butcher box baby put
your box put your box put your box
butcher box i got a fridge full of meat
butcher boxes
still got some ground beef in there yeah
stuff is fine
patties makes a nice bolognese that
ground beef they got gang butcher box
delivered right to your door top quality
meats talking salmon talking pork chops
talking chicken talking beef talking
steaks top shelf stuff absolutely
fantastic yeah everything is a hundred a
hundred percent grass-fed free organic
ranged chicken wild caught seafood and
more wow
wow call uh they're they're sourcing
decisions are made holistically keeping
the form of the plan of the animal and
family all in mind look at that every
munch butcher box ships a curated
selection of high quality meat
right to your home free shipping in the
continental u.s
usa no antibiotics no hormones each box
contains 8 to 14 pounds of meat
depending on what box you choose
you can customize your own box or go
with one of those it's easy peasy either
way you want either either way you get
exactly what you want this is your
chance to never have to shop for ground
beef again that's right butcher boxes
giving this is nuts members free ground
beef for life we told them they're crazy
pull that box butcher boxes giving
members free ground beef for life plus a
10 off coupon sign up at butcherbox.com
ayg and get two pounds of ground beef in
every order for the life of your
membership that's a bananas
uh plus a ten dollar coupon off go to
butcherbox.com ayg to clean this deal do
it do it all right
uh this is from oligamy balls first time
long time is it garbage to have a
picture of dogs playing poker in your
house
to me that was like art
we're not a big art family for about two
weeks in the spring of 88 it was yeah it
went downhill quick it was like those
billy big mouth bass no no this was at
least like billy big man this is [ __ ]
hillbillies and rednecks that's not
there that's not the same this was at
least a drawing of some sort i don't
know
would you put the dogs in the poker
picture in the in the same
thing as talking about the along with
the bulldogs one's got a cigar in his
mouth he's got his nose got his nose
wide open his nose wide open to roulette
tape
he's asking for a 50k marker they're
turning them down uh no but only because
i think it's generational it's like the
dogs poker is more 80s to me big mouth
billy bass that's like 99 early 2000s
yeah but the big man
the
enduring qualities about it the dogs
playing poker was actually yeah yeah you
would find that in like a uh like a
cheers type establishment exactly sure
okay big mouth billy bats is for [ __ ]
mouth breathing i completely and polly
walnuts
ah that's pretty funny though i'll tell
you that what well we had one for sure
that's my advice
my stepdad got it for christmas from his
mom that was a big you know hey we got
one you know
man yeah you ever seen one of those 90s
were tough for us running on low
batteries
it sounds like he's on [ __ ] sounds
like he's on promethazine
yeah the loser sitting in
i don't know what they're dumping in
that river lay off the [ __ ] scissor
will you billy
must be his later stuff
[Laughter]
his last tour this one's a little mean
but
conditionally funny we like mean this is
from tj know anyone that went blind or
deaf
that's tough if it was a medical reason
that's not fun but if it's an accident
it's a little different i'm thinking
fireworks
that's what goes to my mind welding no
mask yeah something like get a bad case
of welder's eye
[Laughter]
that's what i was i was thinking more
like
quarter sticks of dynamite weren't
involved
losing fingers and stuff that is pretty
bad man
[Laughter]
no obviously not a medical condition of
course not this is
in the vein of the show it's more
accidental [ __ ]
dumbass here's a step down from it did
you know anybody blew anything off with
a firework
uh
no not lost a finger specific i got a
[ __ ] i'm surprised you have all your
fingers and toes little [ __ ]
pyromaniac yeah i got one in the eye i
caught a firecracker in the eye
first of all firecracker is trash yeah
their fire works no the firecracker
what's the difference a firework goes in
the air a firecracker is like a [ __ ]
m80 oh you know the difference huh do i
know that i used to peddle this stuff
what are you talking about i had to
connect my dad would go south of the
border every year
[ __ ] come home with a couple of
[ __ ] cherry bombs he's a couple of
mortars too you look at you selling
snakes and silly binders you're going to
stay in there owning a fire i just
watched a little bit of joe dirt
yesterday
good flick as well um
really cracking the books over there huh
this guy
i got the dog we can't leave the [ __ ]
house this thing don't have all these
shots yet this little hellhound running
around i'm calling plus you told us that
you're [ __ ] 40 episodes in the
yellowstone too yeah this guy's
stretching it out
dude he can't leave the house with this
[ __ ] thing
all jammed up
um
i got a m8 or a firecracker not an m80
no there's a firecracker in the eye
i think i
i'm sure i've said this probably at some
point it lit and then went out and then
like pick back up in this kid's house
you stick it in your eye no this kid had
it in his hand and it was like lit and
went s and then fizzled and he's like oh
[ __ ] give me the lighter back and as
he's holding it it [ __ ] re-upped like
down down by the flick it was about to
[ __ ] go off and he went ah and threw
it
and i was standing across from him and
it exploded like here
and [ __ ] i couldn't hold my eye for
like two days oh man yeah it was [ __ ]
bad you must have been bugging out dude
my stepmom's like something she knew
something was up i was like yeah i'm
just real tired because i couldn't open
my eyes
[ __ ] have your heads
it's all black
my hair's all popped up the hell
happened to you not dead i'm screaming
i don't want any supper
i'm gonna head upstairs to get my
homework started it's august
[Laughter]
i finally broke down and told her
because i was just acting like i was i
was laying i was freaking out it was one
of those things
your eyes not moving
you know one of the i i think the the
theory the working theory that day from
her was i blew a chunk of the white part
off
which can happen
i think she's not an optometrist
legally
but that was that was her take she can't
see
who knows
man it was one of those things you know
that paddock when you're like
you're so scared i was scared i was
gonna lose my vision obviously but you
don't want to say it out loud because
then it comes true you know what i mean
i'm like if i can just close and keep my
eyes closed for 48 hours i'll get
through this thing it was bad i got hit
in a rock
your little red rocket i got hit
i took a mule kick that are nuts um i
got hit in the head with a rock when i
was a little kid and uh it was like in
the evening and i tried to just go right
in and go upstairs and go to bed i think
my mom came up in a bathtub mom came in
there later my whole bed was like
covered in blood
what the [ __ ] it's tomato sauce
cause he passed again that i can sleep
it off
did you when you were younger did you
guys ever hit rocks with bats
of course we would have
we called them dirt clods but they were
like
like dirt rocks hard clay yeah kind of
when they were doing construction mud
rocks we called them yeah i think dirt
clods was from like a show at the time
we'd have straight fights with those
things oh yeah and every now and then
i'll [ __ ] yeah a piece of quartz
would be in there [ __ ]
[ __ ] turn the lights off for a second
that's what's happening here
good old-fashioned dirt fight turns bad
my brother hit me with one
turns out it was a corked bat
yeah been there
um
two pounds of coal in there
that's a [ __ ] up question yeah um
[Laughter]
let's see this one is from devin lopez
have you ever used white out on your
sneaks after cleaning them because the
tough marks wouldn't come out i respect
the move i do
it looks okay
i don't resp i get it if you're jammed
up but there's no way it looks good
from like maybe 20 feet away you're like
if i'm i'm looking at t-bone shoes they
look white you get closer and then
you're gonna have to answer to that i
think on leather and like the thick nike
whites
you could pass you know what's a goddamn
miracle tool that i don't know what the
[ __ ] it's let me guess
what magic eraser i would the [ __ ] mr
clean things the white john
what the i don't know what the [ __ ] that
whatever
dude it'll take anything off of anything
i'll fix your credit if i can make
anything go away i got a 780. dude i'm
telling you yeah it's a little water on
that thing i don't get it man i think
it's rubbing off on there i think that's
all it is is a big chunk of whiteout
just covers it up yeah that's what
they're doing it's insane uh no
i don't know what i remember when that
dropped my mom had them and that was
like they should have been behind glass
like only using a case of emergency
because they were still probably right
next to the core seating or whatever
they were probably still like 12 bucks a
clip for like two of them you know now
they're like two three bucks
but back then that was like so
[ __ ] useful brand new technology now
there's like the generic versions and
[ __ ] you can get a couple but they're
not as good no that magic eraser man mr
clean you know what works on the code
he was on his last legs too
yeah he needed that no nobody eats that
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] out of here um
toothpaste on shoes too toothpaste and a
toothbrush
that's how you used to clean your first
ones back then in high school toothpaste
on a cold sore two works pretty good yak
dry it out so i've heard dry it out yeah
dry it out
ah man
cut yourself shaving again yeah okay
full beard i got punched
by a herpe every three to six weeks
i keep getting punched in my genitals
[Laughter]
is it flaring up in here is it me
this one's from
mcliven uh how many boogers are under
the driver's seat of your car mine is
like sandpaper down there
yikes
i i'm assuming yours isn't great out the
window i flick i roll i flick like a
gentleman there's no way i believe that
yeah i'll flick it in my car i'm not
putting it under my thing like wiping
them off
ah i mean it's not gum listen i'm pretty
my car has been pretty good there's a
there's a couple of stalag tights down
there
you got a couple of mine in there too
i'm sure yeah you're not looking on the
highway i do a little digging hey i'm
gonna check and see what's going on
uh you have to mark my territory you're
never allowed back in my car ever again
ever again
that's too [ __ ] good the thought of
your boogers we've been in more almost
fistfights over your boogers than
anything else it's a point of contention
i know
it's me trying to stay as far away from
your boogers as possible and they're
constantly encroaching on my personal
space
it's like trench warfare with you
every day they move a little bit closer
we call truce on christmas
all right this one's a this one's
actually a pro move to me this is from
scott is it garbage to order pickup from
the restaurant your roommate is
currently working at but never pick it
up so he can take it home for free
that's putting the whole [ __ ] system
on trial that is wow that's something i
would have never
ever thought about damn
that's like that sounds like white
collar crime that's yeah talk about
cooking the book jesus yeah there's
there's accomplices in that if you're
doing that a lot that's [ __ ] up to the
restaurant
they can afford a burrito or a [ __ ]
side of chickie fingers maybe probably i
doubt you're still you know what if it's
an applebee's they can afford him [ __ ]
him you're stealing from a [ __ ] mom
and pop shop he's trying to you know
keep and make ends put the kids through
college sure yeah but if it's a [ __ ]
fridays [ __ ] pot stickers all day
let's go yeah [ __ ] open it up
i'd be pissed open up the pipeline
look at the black market
broccoli and cheese let's do it uh
that's genius yeah i've never even
[ __ ] thought about that um all right
this one's from andy feathersnatch
haven't had a question right yet
i think it's dr andy is it garbage to
sign your buddy up for a ton of free
magazines car cruise ship giveaway so he
gets bombarded with mail and phone calls
that's good old-fashioned fun yeah
that's a good time gelato it's a dick
dick move what a good old that's that's
all right this last time you saw a
magazine we get them you do the the uh
the bird she's you know an
are you a southern living house nah the
new yorker
really yeah i thought you were lying
when you told me that now you get the
new yorker what's that come once a week
i don't even know they're still all in
the mailbox really i don't empty the
mail i open the mailbox i make sure
there's no packages in there and
sometimes that
we have this you know this rough rough
rough broad who just is like [ __ ]
uppercut packages into my box because
they're so it's so take it out i don't
check the mail there's nothing in there
for me except bad news you want money i
ain't got it
what do you want from me interesting
articles in the new yorker plus yeah
we get to we get the new yorker there's
a couple in there there's a i think
probably monthly the new yorker i'd have
to assume yeah i'm not cranking that out
of everything i don't i don't even know
if she reads it yeah
trying to look cool for the neighbors i
get it yeah flex on them my new yorker
somebody see my new yorker yeah by the
way we lost another package i think the
thief
[Music]
this is a little off tangent but have
you seen our friend reggie conquest's
stories of some guy broke into his
uh building and stole all of the
packages
and then he was put it all on instagram
and then they they pulled the
surveillance oh yeah he was like trying
the [ __ ] dude he walked right out front
opened up all the packages it was like
holding the shirts up to him on his like
it's like all right this dude he was
doing he was doing the pants and like
putting the leg out to make sure it fits
yeah it's imagine the confidence this
[ __ ] has to start trying it on
right out front it's awesome yeah
yeah they're [ __ ] they're they're
relentless with that [ __ ] i know i
peeked into my uh paper towels yesterday
see what was in there who i don't know
all right same guy
you're on oh you order paper towels yeah
shoulders paper towels
why'd you answer it like that i don't
know
we did we do the amazon uh like month is
like subscription
no we're not [ __ ] i'm not subscribed
to paper towels a lot of people do that
really i just subscribed to cat food
i think i got a monster for him i think
i got a monthly
no commercials or nothing
[ __ ] bounty plus now yeah a lot of
people do that
thank you
i'm trying to get one in there for a
couple of seconds
um
the amazon [ __ ] i don't know we i
don't know we had to spend 35 bucks
though
yeah
so she got paper towels and some
perriers
okay [ __ ] fancy pants no wonder you
were hitting me up for the youtube money
yesterday
this guy's [ __ ] you're getting
sparkly water delivered to your house
well i also had a shipment of uh this
guy come on i had a shipment of
stormtroopers that came in i got a squat
i got six and eight sleeping
i ordered them in a mandalorian
and they all got there
they got there safely but i was worried
about they were going to steal them
downstairs that'd be a jackpot you open
it up it's all toys [ __ ] bastards
but they ripped one part of the box to
see that it was just uh paper towels and
left it alone took a roll but what are
you gonna do
you gotta wet your beak i get it
stealing packages is a hard job
uh i would love to catch one of those
it doesn't bother me in the building
would bother me that like i said i i'd
have to live with them but other than
that i don't give away yeah i was ready
someone's coming in under like a
delivery driver [ __ ] guys and
stealing [ __ ] you know
my dog treats [ __ ] take them i don't
care i don't like that [ __ ] so that's if
i was reggie and saw that dude out front
yeah that'd be a [ __ ] problem do you
ever see the videos where people go up
on the porch oh i saw some nickel the
guy opens the door with nickel like
where the [ __ ] you go like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] take it
down the street yeah that's great i love
watching the videos where they like fall
and slip and one pulls up
that's such a scum [ __ ]
such a dirtbag [ __ ] move not really
because it gets replaced so you're
really ripping off big business
it's a white-collar crime not if you're
waiting on this like robin hood no
they're not like they're not giving that
out in the neighborhoods like turkeys
yeah but they're stealing from the
from the big guy they're stealing from
you you bought you paid for that yeah
but then it's my goddamn stormtrooper it
gets replaced i want to play with my
toys if i go home expecting it to be
there and it's not there i'd be upset
especially if it's my periaceous well
you can cry using your paper towels and
relax with a [ __ ] period
what kind of pair plain you go lemon no
uh
these are you order a box of them i said
it's like a [ __ ] they're cans first
of all there's the little european cans
is peach peach yeah we have peach what
are you guys having parties without me
what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] came over for
dinner is it the jacket i'll take it off
right now i'll take it off
you guys are hanging out having
sparkling waters no wonder why you
weren't with me on trashing them on the
sparkling water
you're up to your [ __ ] ears in them
you guys are over there swimming in
[ __ ] peach peach perrier
i'm drinking [ __ ] awesome and jana
purely
what the [ __ ] is this
what is this you think you you think
you're partners with these guys t-bones
bought and paid for
on a subscription basis too
damn it's like an oligarch over there i
got a corner
i'm doing my bidding
i start putting sanctions on t-bone
listen what
i'm gonna put how about i start putting
some economic [ __ ] sanctions on you
that's what i'm gonna do listen
i haven't done anything wrong yeah you
haven't done anything right either
though listen
uh there's little the little cans
like i don't know like packs of 12. i
got a watermelon a peach and i got a
thing of lacroix too the crocs nice
drinking i'm drinking a shitload of that
stuff okay i don't is it good for you is
it okay i know it's better than you do
but is it okay for you uh
it's really russian it's really bad for
your teeth they say
real that's what that's what dennis told
me it really takes the enamel off your
teeth really and it's even worse if you
drink it and then brush because it
loosens it it softens it and then you
brush it away that's what they told me
but that could have been that one
dentist who doesn't know what he's
talking about yeah no [ __ ]
he could have been the one out of ten
yeah the guy who doesn't sign off on
colgate the guy who doesn't like trident
yeah [ __ ]
i can't be worried about that what uh
enamel that's nice
enamel is on the bottom of your list
what carbonated water even can still
lead to erosion into your tooth enamel
lead to doesn't necessarily happen uh
but it's better than uh but is a better
option than drinking soda of course yeah
i remember the dentist asked me she's
like yeah you're enamel you know
whatever she goes do you drink a lot of
diet soda or soda i said shoulder i said
diet like trying to like that's all
right she's like how many i'm like i
don't know six a day what are we doing
who's on trial here that's give me my
free cleaning then let me get out of
here
take a spin at the toy chest and be on
about my day i told you that was when i
went to the guy my wife got it on
groupon
to go get a cleaning
and i walk in and
did you ever hear that story i gotta
glue my petco
they put me on a leash right away
you give me one of those greenies to
chew on
greedies and a muzzle
dental work should never be done on a
deal yeah dude that's shifting yeah what
do you want from me
groupon's real trashy
man the bird went through a phase of it
a couple of years ago you can spot
people that use groupon like pigeons
when they walk in do you know they're
there dude if you show up to like a
restaurant you got something printed out
it's a bad luck it's 4 30 you're having
dinner
uh we stopped taking groupon dinners at
9am i apologize
i hope you like dinner omelets
[Laughter]
i like to meet little farmland and who
had the pot roast
[Laughter]
yeah they tried to bamboozle you too i
mean they did they tried to really yeah
that's what you get when you use groupon
you're playing at the end i know they
said you needed some ultra cleaning or
something something you try to give me
some sort of like
a gum line periodontist gum line type
[ __ ] yeah and i was like listen and
they sit you down with like a salesman
like it's a car dealership that's why
i'm a lot man they see you down with a
they say [ __ ] give me my bubble gum
fluoride
oh man that stuff regardless of the
flavor makes me gag that gets you back
at the bottom of the in the back of the
tongue that thing yikes i can feel it
there's like getting waterboarded
after the cleaning are you looking for
that i think i got a small mouth too so
like all that stuff sucked
kip mint mobile mint mobile mint
mobility like save the money who don't
like saving money oh you don't like
savings i said who don't oh that's right
that's right everyone loves saving i
don't know who who this who character is
but i'll tell you who does like save
them who dad everybody else loves it i
know your lady likes to save money she's
a mint mobile user for years at this
point way before they were even 15 bucks
a month over there at mint mobile gang
get on it no contracts no rigmarole no
nothing yeah straight to the source and
you know who's one of the owners that
ryan reynolds oh really not two not too
shabby uh by going uh online and
eliminating the traditional cost of
retail mint mobile pays is the
significant savings on to you
all plans come with unlimited talk tax
and high speed data delivered on your
nation's largest 5g network use your own
phone and with any mint mobile plan you
keep your same number along with all
your existing contacts it's not like
you're starting over from the beginning
it's just an easy quick switch over with
them if you're changing your number
you're trash yeah with mint mobile
choose the amount of monthly data that's
right for you and stop paying for data
you'll never use switch with mint mobile
and get premium wireless service done at
just 15 beans a month
to get your new wireless plan for just
15 bucks a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage cut your wireless
blow to 15 bucks a month one more time
mintmobile.com garbage do it helix helix
you have one i got one it's gonna sleep
on it every night pop-pop don't act like
you don't know what i'm talking about
they sent you a free bed meanwhile i'm
standing on a call with none ah best bet
on my best mattress of my life yeah i
feel like an adult finally me and my
wife it's awesome we signed up took to
two minute quiz got the twilight
mattress don't gotta go to the store
don't gotta like roll around on a bed
someone else has rolled around on
talking to some bozo commission guy on
working working commission on sales kick
rocks probably wearing that jacket
helix sleep like we said takes two
minutes matches your body type and sleep
preference uh for the perfect mattress
for you yeah uh why would you want to
sleep on a mattress that's not right
what are you an idiot
what are we even talking about
they deliver right to the house so if
you're looking for a mattress take the
quiz you order the mattress your match
when it comes right to your door ship
for free don't even have to go to the
mattress store ever again like the big
man said yeah just go to
garbage take the quiz they'll match you
with a customized mattress give you the
best leap of your life have a 10-year
warranty on it and you get to try it out
free for a hundred nights risk-free
believe it pick it up if you don't love
it but i'm telling you you will 100
knights is holding they even have
financing options that are flexible
payment plans to make a great night's
sleep not too far away listen to this
the call to action get ready helix is
offering up to 200 200 beans 200 clams
of all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
healixsleep.com garbage one more time at
heelsleep.com back to that show back to
the show
sucked i hated it
smallmouth kippy dr spadafora can kick
rocks
um
but i went in and then they gave me this
hard sell hard sell they sent me down
like yeah dude this was when i'm poor
enough
this is like four years ago i'm poor
three years ago i'm poor enough that i'm
using groupon dennis that's where i'm at
and he throws a number at me that was
like 48 hundo to get this thing done
with a straight face
yeah but he's got a mouth full of gear
too and i'm like i think he's working
these braces off to be honest
i think he's upside down in a set of
chompers this guy this guy's selling
spare parts out of his mouth yeah i'm
sitting there i'm like dude they got you
now you're trying to get us like a
pyramid scheme look kevin what you want
to do is yeah yeah we're six plan monty
talking like kanye
uh
through the wire so um
i was like i'm [ __ ] out i'm like yeah
do they still they still hit me up hey
just following up you gotta schedule
your i'm just like now in a database i
can't shake the mets i went to a [ __ ]
one mech game last year [ __ ] emails
they're calling me i want you to be mr
met they're like hey this is jan from
the mets uh you know the ticket packs
like what the [ __ ] out of here yeah
jesus christ that's how they get you
nuts
[ __ ] sucking us in [ __ ] [ __ ]
uh this is from aaron uh thanks so much
for this podcast it's very sweet never
had a question red ever pulled away with
the gas pump still in your
[Laughter]
me and my brother saw a lady just
right out of the parking lot you got to
be real ditched yeah she was a she was
an old bag this one
was what was happening a couple of moms
growing up [ __ ] got caught up in that
now they're detached i don't know when
they started but they became detachable
because so many people were just ripping
them out and then like gas was spraying
everywhere it got to the point where
it's like you got to hit the button and
the whole place gets [ __ ] hansel
system dude
that's over then one of those goes off
that'll ruin dude that'll ruin the
neighborhood
[ __ ] dogs from dogs heads head to the
top of the mountain dude it's like it's
like fluorescent yeah it comes out heavy
bike it's like a groupon foam party
let's pop some molly and [ __ ] party
at the exxon a bunch of zoo balls fall
out or whatever they're called what are
those things called those little beads
that like plump up in water
no
zoobles something i don't know looks
like you ate them though
the kids do the tricks they do the
things with them all the time i don't
know squabbles they'll fill a whole
backyard wobble bobbles huh i don't know
it sounds like weed yourself
trying to get that wobble bobble orbeez
orbeez
there you go sounds like a knockoff
orbeez
come on down to orbeez that's the roast
beef not good
not roast beef
how's the roast beef goat new orbeez not
roast beef
[Laughter]
orbeez we have some meat
it's in parentheses
we'll find something for you
orbeez
orbeez you're going to leave hungry
[Laughter]
orbeez
that was you guys why that was your
generation wasn't it orbeez yeah what
i tell you we're like no
orbeez isn't real what are you an alien
yeah there's [ __ ] they're the little
[ __ ] things oh those i would tell you
i was still talking about the
the chain restaurant
we have some investors i didn't play
with those no what i don't know too busy
[ __ ] stealing sigs what are you
talking you were up to toby definitely
from my dad counting marlboro miles no
that's that's gen z that's younger than
us yeah that's like tick tockers and
stuff orbeez and a betta fish oh we were
my sister had a betta fish put him in
the bathtub
got him okay i got anyone after my wee
wee
i spit it back out
peter showed
[Music]
up all right this one uh
this is from tristan haven't had one
ready you guys know this one's a kind of
a softball i think you guys know anyone
that got a dui in high school
oh yeah yeah i had a buddy get two
before he turned his license in
for the first one he got it second in
his driveway they don't [ __ ] what yeah
yikes
they followed him to his house and
pulled into his driveway
it's [ __ ] up and he blew under the
legal limit but he wasn't 21. so there
is technically no legal limit we had a
buddy who got busted at a party uh man
don't drink and drive out there of
course we hear that we had a buddy that
got busted um we all got arrested at a
party
uh the house party in the middle of
night my sophomore year he hid under the
bed or something like that got away uh
and we were all at the [ __ ] at the
precinct or whatever his dad showed up
because he had heard there was a party
and just assumed that he got busted
rolled in in a [ __ ] trench coat and
his [ __ ] jammies on
and they were like oh i guess we got one
loose out there they picked him up
[ __ ] walking down the highway trying
to walk home a couple hours later
this old man ratted him out
there's my idiot son pull over right
here
damn
dewey's in high school were dangerous
especially now
don't get one now yeah
well like literally pennsylvania's thing
is like you don't drink and drive you
can't afford it they really held me up
yeah it's not good don't do it
i do not advise it
especially wearing that coat
you've been drinking you know it
i look like a [ __ ] to you
it's also like i don't get any more
uber's so easy jump in jump out leave
the car not in [ __ ] the suburbs items
there's uber i i know but i drive by
bars and stuff like that that are like
the parking lots
i never understood that i'm like can a
cop be like just sit across somebody's
drinking and driving out they're not all
there for the chicken fingers you know
what i mean
doing the open mic
[Applause]
uh all right this one is from the mayor
of foleyville saint vayne have you run
out of your met have you or any member
of your family ever been in a high-speed
chase
[Laughter]
ever ran i never did there was a kid
growing up i would freak out kid growing
up did
he was taking his uh brother's car's
dad's car or something it was my
brother's buddy when they were like 15.
in the middle of the night he would
sneak out get the car go pick up all the
boys
right and like drive around i guess
smoking cigs i don't know weed whatever
um
and he went to pick everybody up and no
one went with like everybody could get
out you know what i mean this is like
before cell phone so like he would just
like roll up in front of the house and
like you know
if he could get him he whatever so he's
just like cruising around by himself and
he got away got pulled over for like
making a you know whatever so he got
pulled and ran and took off oh
like cop out of the car
like the cop had made contact i don't
know i don't i don't know just taking
off on the cop car is one thing if you
get [ __ ] pulled over and then that's
the way yes sir right there i think
that's the way to do it because they're
out of the car
you get a head start i mean if we're if
we're playing for keeps here
i'm playing [ __ ] patty cake
let him get up he gotta run hold up they
they always chase the car for a half a
second
[ __ ]
where are my keys uh yikes dude he went
through a whole the whole town
he had everybody he had like he had a
crew he had like every cop on duty they
were coming in he had like six cars
chasing him and he finally crashed
through the front of uh
it just so happened the front of the
house of my sister's best friend
and who we ended up they like went to
school together and knew holy [ __ ] yeah
it was wild hey mrs fielder where are
you in one of those
i'll see you at the danes
it's getting tased
[Laughter]
yeah no no runners nothing like that
that's crazy to me crazy scary i've
never really been pulled over i'm not
that good of a driver oh i know so i i
can't i can't i can't have pulled over
for breaking at a green light
i can't handle the the anxiety of that
high-speed chase dude sometimes slow
down
on the bqe you know where there's no
shoulder and it's like it's kind of like
676 in philly where it's like yeah it's
kind of not underground but like it's
like that huge nowhere to go there's
nowhere to go there's like [ __ ] 50
foot walls on either side of you
and i'm driving home from a [ __ ] show
or something in like westchester and uh
it's at night and this car like [ __ ]
you know some like fast [ __ ] beamer
or whatever is like [ __ ] zigzagging
all over but i'm like holy [ __ ] like i'm
cooking i'm doing 70 or so i'm 60 or 70.
and this guy [ __ ] passes me easy work
like it's nothing
dude then i guess he didn't see this cop
and this cops flying but they're keeping
like he goes and then maybe like
six seconds later a cop comes with
lights off
no headlights on it's two guys in an suv
no headlights on no sirens just at night
yeah i guess to catch up with like i
guess their thought is like
if we can get closer and then we'll
light them up damn i don't know it was
the dude they that's when i was like i
was like oh that shit's real who's the
[ __ ] hero car doing 120 with the
lights off you're like whoa [ __ ] rigs
and murtaugh in there
i didn't see him until they passed me
damn like you get the [ __ ] in the car
shakes a little
yeah i'm not a high-speed guy what about
you i'd imagine he's never driven a car
i've driven a car
when illegally every time
i imagine a couple of your bucks you
gotta run if you get pulled over oh yeah
no you don't you just take the [ __ ]
fine you don't run toby you never run um
all right let's see this one is from
terence
uh
do small appliances stay on the counter
the toaster the blender are they put
away after each use i don't know which
is trashier
uh because my mom puts hers away
and that shelf is usually covered in
crumbs yeah that's bad we have a nice
toaster too but it looks good out like
you're there's not cluttered no yeah
it's good no there's no clutter
but
i don't know that's a real that's a real
tough question
when it comes to that kind of stuff you
got like a blender out i mean you keep
like a nice kitchenaid out
that thing's all right but that's more
of a showpiece yeah so the bird has
she's you know into the expensive
kitchen appliances culinary arts and
juicers the breville juicers the
nutribullet you can't keep those out
after a couple of uses because they get
that film on well that's typically
[ __ ] me cleaning it all the [ __ ]
time um
you gotta do that right away oh i know
otherwise it's trash i know she hasn't
been using it recently i don't care how
healthy you are but she has like we
bought like one of those like [ __ ]
bought it on craigslist uh bunch of
cucumber guts everywhere oh man that
stuff turns right quick too it's like
[Laughter]
[ __ ] earthworms in the kitchen i know
um every doubt again you guys sync up
like a sorority
it's calls for besties
[Laughter]
hi it's kevin there
oh my god it's me
[Laughter]
um
i know what's going on out there
uh what the [ __ ] were we just talking
about oh but breaking news on said are
you garbage podcast
that's what i just bought
air fryer yes
knew it
yeah that's where you got the jacket
from
you were at a goddamn airfryer show
i did an air show just an air fryer show
the blue fat guys are over there
fat guys
that one guy just did an inverted
chicken wing
yeah i got the air fryer but nowhere to
put it
we haven't i haven't even can't leave
those out on the counter they get all
greasy i know that's like i haven't even
that's why i always said toaster ovens
were trash because nobody maintained
them no after like after one summer of
[ __ ] you know elios and bagels yeah a
thousand grilled cheese and bagel bites
that thing was disgusting look like
satan's floor
it's all right my dad used to do the tin
foil on it and then you would that gets
all covered
up no but at the bottom but that made it
easier to clean
it tighter yeah should we we do the tin
foil system i don't like it i don't like
the tinfoil system well i'm gonna have
to i'm gonna have to let you know how i
feel about said air fryer you haven't
used it yet have we got it the same day
we got the dog and it's just been
[ __ ] running around you know
cleaning up [ __ ] and putting dog food in
there
he likes it in there for three minutes a
couple of milk bones yeah
yeah um
i think you got to put that stuff away
yes but it pretends how it looks but i
always felt trashy growing up going and
going that's weird you want to make
toast a toaster you got to go into the
closet for toast yeah bad luck we do
keep things in that closet too
there's a couple kitchen items in our
coat closet in the front of the house
for sure
she'll go in every once in a while to
get the big pot yeah when you got to get
the big pot of the big skillet yeah
yeah she's digging around in there pull
out the crock pot yeah it's got it's got
a knitted hat in it
it's got scarves in it
dude no [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that
no that's weird you can't be keeping
kitchen stuff with non-kitchen stuff
that's too hard oh we have stuff out in
the [ __ ] garage like we're a catering
company with something big pops off
where the sternum oh yeah behind the box
of rolls
can't be keeping rolls next to the
[ __ ] motor oil right next to the
shock for the pool
ah
we're out of salt use a little bit of
the shock just a pinch
this is a pin a pinch and a shock will
take care of it
what's the secret ingredient in this
chlorine it's good
don't have too much
uh
that's a tough look yeah i feel if it
falls on if it looks okay if it's too
close you know one or two things is okay
a blender if you got the space for it
can i say there's a toaster on the low
i'm a huge toast guy
toast
huge trusty at the house with a fresh
thing of butter
man they're all getting lined up there's
not one empty slot in there
[ __ ] cherries all across the board so
i like guy fat guy five guys i like to
use the toaster okay i enjoy a good
toaster yeah maybe lay off the bread i
have been
why would i believe that
because i don't have a toaster you just
said i have a toaster i love making
toast at my i meant it my parents
i don't know settings on this the
settings of this story really changed
midway i feel like i'm in an m night
shyamalan story
wait i'm fat the toaster was dead the
whole time
have you ever done or no i do have a
toaster
but i don't know what we're talking
about we are we are in
i do have a toaster i was telling you an
anecdote on the on the pod and you
immediately jumped on me it's not what
i'm doing now i'm just saying in general
i appreciate that doesn't mean that i'm
doing it now
that's all have you have you guys seen
the move where
uh
someone either you or someone you know
has been hot dogs in a toaster
no that's your thing hot dogs in a
toaster hotdog is a toaster oven oh hot
dogs in a toaster no hot dogs in a
microwave
two hot dogs in a microwave for a minute
52 seconds depending on the wattage it's
not a problem no it's fantastic
fantastic i'll throw in a [ __ ] dude
those oscar mayer cheese dogs with the
g's in the middle they do blow up like
an old man's nose though
some of them get looked like they've
been drinking too long
yeah someone get a case of rosacea
um yeah that's i mean
i would come home from school
high school or junior high two of them
in the two of them on a paper plate hit
the easy minute button
right
get the two martin's potatoes
i get the two martin's potato buns out
[ __ ] put them on
throw them on the thing after the minute
and they throw a [ __ ] hand two
handfuls of [ __ ] goldfish on the side
of that plate two cans of coke called a
[ __ ] two episodes of inspector gadget
and i'm golden more of a trl and four
more years of virginity
he eats hot dogs four more years of
virginity
here we go
here's your four more years here
juggernaut into peanut butter
what was your protocol what was the uh
was there a defense system for uh
incoming phone calls at your house when
you were a child well you was there a
script of what to say my dad was
never here never i mean mainly a lot of
people yeah i mean for legal purposes he
wasn't it was i'm not here i'm not here
every time i would like to the point
where the phone ring if he didn't say
something i go dad are you here no i'm
not here yeah he's not here all right
it'd be like his brother he'd be like
i'm not i'm
i'm like oh hey uncle bill i'm thinking
of my dad's like i'm not here not here
yeah
that that they don't even answer the
phone at my mom's anymore
they don't even answer it i don't even
know if it's on
really i don't think the ringer is on it
comes up on the tv because it's through
comcast too which annoys the [ __ ] out
typically for years and also
i did them real dirty for years it was
all of my creditors calling the house
ouch every single one of them i'm
talking student loans i'm talking amex
i'm talking macy's they say he doesn't
live here
yeah but they go i don't give a [ __ ]
it's just some guy in a [ __ ] call
center he's like yeah of course you're
gonna say he doesn't live here that's
what they all say i'm not [ __ ] taking
your word for it you're deadbeat i can
smell that fat bastard from here he's
making hot dogs i can hear them
why do i hear goldfish shaking around
like dice
i'm in the back i'm not here um
yeah so i really [ __ ] them
really like it was like
it was like terrorized like i mean six a
day seven a day if i got one if i got
five years one of those at the house
she's on the phone and what they're
calling here looking for you
amex cult this is bad amex called my
sister-in-law's mother
asking for kevin ryan wow yeah i got a
call from i i get a text from my brother
do you have a name he's working at case
colombo
[Laughter]
they exhausted every resource
holy [ __ ] i got interviewing your
teachers and [ __ ] i got a text from my
brother going do you have an amex card
not in the scent like you could read the
tone wasn't like let's be amex buddies
this was a what the [ __ ] it wasn't a
huge right
yeah it wasn't where amex did you have
an amex card is that one yes do you have
a do you have a pass through amex card
cause they're currently looking for the
400 beans holy [ __ ] yeah calling jesus
for 400 bucks embarrassing me in front
of my in-laws for 400. buddy i'll get it
to you what do you want
400 amex needs my 400 meanwhile it was
200 and they [ __ ] they juiced me
probably got two out of the ant too
can't catch a [ __ ] break around here
that's trash
good lord
not my finest moment now i can't see her
without
feeling like a complete complete
mother-in-law too sit again you're my
sis my
sister-in-law's
my brother's wife's mother wow so it'd
be like how many times have you met this
woman enough
for her to know my dirtbag
i mean the creditors calling her house
didn't what are they pictures with you
two together i don't understand how they
make that connection you're really
married into a great family
what's your social security number
i'm at the wedding i'm at the wedding
writing down credit card numbers
let me see i'm putting together a
scrapbook for the kids i'll need all the
kids socials
you're about to buy some property uncles
are walking up to your brother it's
really great your brother's running that
coach he's like
i never heard of a wallet check at a
wedding before so your brother works
your mastercard huh
man i was a loser for a real i still am
as i'm sitting here wearing this jacket
man i was a loser for a really long time
yeah until you took it home at the
winston cup
for
can we go to a nascar race yeah for sure
there are so many can you get us in yeah
i'll get you i'm [ __ ] i'll get you on
pit lane i get in the infield you're
gonna show your titties
please be 18 please be 18.
i'd want to do it right one of those
winnebagos out there in the middle of
the field we can do it yeah yeah
fireworks and [ __ ]
what okay
i don't know what that means
uh yeah maybe we get the pace car pull
some strings get the [ __ ] out of here do
that you can't get in the i'm not saying
i can pull straight this jacket has gone
to your head there's no way you're
getting us in the pace car
not off anybody i'm saying we can make
some sort of donation or something get
us in there
i don't know anybody can get us an
update
that's not what i was implying to the
flag oh that was the big thing you used
to have [ __ ] we were racing outside
the checkered flags thought you were so
[ __ ] cool whipping it down white flag
last lap i think forget
the checkered flags real hillbilly [ __ ]
bad shout out to flemington raceway
home of the dirtbags
that jacket's thanks
we'll get used to it fatty it's coming
on tour this week
um let's see let's do one or two more
and then get out of here this one's just
funny this is jared uh ever watched two
years worth of patreon content in two
months because tax time is the only time
you have extra cash ah
but what you gotta do baby game the
system i'm all about do what you gotta
do this one i don't i literally don't
it's
this is from tool have you tool i guess
have you ever worn goggles in the shower
so you don't have to close your eyes and
give the monsters a chance to get you
buddy you gotta see you gotta you gotta
check out betterhelp.com but i do get it
i get it in the sense that shower
curtain can be a little sketchy i have
never washed my hair in complete comfort
at any stage of my life even now when
i'm in there i'm not [ __ ] in vidal
sassoon land i got [ __ ] my eyes in
the back i'm on my six now let me ask
you this in the shower okay
what are you
what's the door situation
are you closing and locking the door
fully you open you cracked what are you
doing like the door to the bathroom
uh i don't think yeah i don't lock the
bathroom door
if you did that would be suspect
i would assume yeah that's that's
playing a little patty cake that was
always suspect in my house growing up
lock in the bathroom even if you the
bathroom door no what if you're in there
taking a boom boom
everybody knows you're in there i'm
taking i'm in the bathroom so let's just
say you're sitting around watching tv
you have to go hey guys i'm going to go
take a dude we were knocked for we were
knock first people when
if i was in the shower and patty knocked
on the door
and
she couldn't get in to get her tweezers
or whatever she had to get to oh yeah
lock that top pop up then you got to get
out you're wet
i just had to push it open
oh yeah you're doing that what that's
crazy she's trying to get her [ __ ]
hairspray get the [ __ ] out of here wow
there's no privacy like that
now well older
i mean if i was down if you went if you
went into your parents house now to
shower you i've locked the door yeah
yeah now i can wow he had 46 look at you
big man on campus locking the door hey
ma i'll do whatever i want i can beat
her up now
as a kid she was a tough cookie i'll
tell you that damn got a [ __ ] right
hand on her
look at wow put you to sleep that's
crazy
oh yeah and now
you know in my in my apartment i you
know
not worried no i think that would be
uh
a sign of distrust or something like
that if i lock the door yeah i wouldn't
do that
i know she's not coming in the way i'm
[ __ ] doping
and in the shower see what happens you
know what i mean well you gotta brush
your teeth and stuff like that no no no
no locking of the doors yeah bedrooms
neither
they knew he was a kid no oh yeah you
couldn't lock your bedroom door and
they're defiling myself yeah so i had to
work under the cover of darkness
i was taught to look over my shoulders
early in life jesus christ keep it quiet
yeah i mean not locking the bedroom
doors i totally get but we were able to
lock our bathroom plus well we had a my
mom had a sister too though my mom had
the the
my mom locked it growing up
could you do that now
i'd pop in there and sneak a peek
uh see what the bible stuff but my mom
had her own bathroom and then the kids
had one
what'd you say
see what the bible was talking about
i meant adam and eve because they were
naked
i don't know [ __ ] about the bible i
thought they were [ __ ] moms yeah
hey freud you all done
all right let's wrap it up gang we love
yous we're on tour right now yes we are
we got new dates coming new dates coming
they're probably announced by this point
uh
the west coast a couple of cities on the
west coast will be coming to town it's
gonna be fun yes so come out and see us
we have a great time bring the squad
bring the gang we love you very much
we'll see you next week
peace